và trụ chành của Bụ Mí Sao, lâm biết dùng, thương nhận cho đàn em đập phá xe,
giang cảnh tên an chình cầu tốc để em cơ đừng bị vẫn chuyển đưa hàng vào cơ sử và nục viết,
hưởng lợi Bụ Mí Thì Đông.
Phó nhìn sẽ không có nhiều được tối thì vụ thèo nó,
cãnh chở dầu thậm nó, để đa dá hành chậm.
Nhưng mà nhiều chẳng gõi dầu, chẳng tôi thì mục phí thù phí,
dợi dợi hành là bà chục bà chục nghe.
Mục lất tôi là theo cãnh chở dầu thông,
tập phá xe là để mạnh người là mục lo sợ,
để nếu đem dầu trần của tôi để tình thù phí kìm đẹp.
Để cho phí dân cình dân của Bí kết in của tôi,
để người ta dầu trần của tôi.
Rục đau đi thì cũng mình hợp.
Nhưng sau một số đối tượng,
đích càng đối tài xe,
bình xe thôi, đối tối.
Rồi ra dãi, vĩ là mạng nghe một kính,
vĩ đều kính là phải đi qua,
hình xúc cũng xo hạn nghe nguyên.
Đó là không thể có tổ không nguyên của hạn tình chân.
Thì sau đó một số đối tượng này,
thì mặt đầu tượng đặc đó là xe của mình tổ thời,
để linh tục được chắc đà là bí đặc xe.
Bí đặc xe,
xe một hạn nào là xe dầu cố lým ra,
và bà phù tình tà đến những người thì một số đối tượng là
dụng đá, dụng đá, dụng đá, dụng đá, dụng đá, dụng đá,
bóng đúng là.
Mà sau đó là tích tục hình bí đe,
bóng đá, dụng đá, dụng đá,
dụng đá, dụng đá,
dụng đá, dụng đá.
Lấy xe, có tình kìa tệ nạn mặt chăm,
dụng đá, hình hoa, chả dờ không được truyền bây,
và giống mình chuyện.
Hình phí đổi lên người ở đây cao.
Tổ mi hạn của nó, đó thêm chứa xe không khó.
Đó là một căm chèo,
thầy kiến xe nhỏ là một căm chèo.
Dù tính tình,
chút bây, mấy,
gùi chết,
đặc buồn phải chàng đó.
Hình trống bé, hình mập bình trống có nè
Hình hình bông xáu kìa, hình biết hình chào